hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code so today let's
solve diameter of binary tree we're
given the root of a binary tree and we
want to return the length of the
diameter of the tree which is defined as
being the longest path from a particular
node so in this case it would basically
be the longest path on the left side
which could either be this part or this
part both of those are of length two I'm
getting that calculation because two is
the number of edges on that side for the
longest path on the right side we just
have one Edge so that's one so the
diameter through the root would be 2 + 1
which is 3 but keep in mind that the
longest path might not necessarily run
through the route so let's look at a
counter example with this tree if we try
to calculate the diameter through the
root on the left side we have nothing so
that's a zero on the right side we have
three that's the longest path you could
take multiple different paths but all of
them are going to be of length three so
the diameter from here is three but
consider the node over here length on
the left side is two and length on the
right side is two so total is four
that's the diameter of this tree now I
want to mention to you that this problem
is actually closer to a medium problem
than an easy problem why exactly is that
because the solution initially seems
pretty obvious right to get the result
we can just try to calculate that
diameter through every single node in
the tree how do you do that well just
like I did get the longest path on the
left and the longest path on the right
and add them together AKA sort of like
the height on the left side and the
height on the right side generally we do
this recursively with some kind of DFS
algorithm but the tricky part about this
problem is that the return value
obviously of this DFS is going to be the
height so what we want to return from
this right subtree up to this node is of
course the height but that's not the
result that we're ultimately trying to
compute what we're actually trying to
compute is the diameter now in terms of
the code there are multiple ways of
handling that the way I'll show you is
sort of by using a member variable or
you can even think of it as sort of a
global variable with respect to the
recursive function but the algorithm
will be exactly like this recursively
run DFS from the left sub tree we reach
null so the height of that of course is
going to be zero that's what we return
up here then do the same on the right
side and then we'd continuously go down
and so here we'd reach the case with
just a node the height of that we will
say is going to be one that's going to
be returned up to the parent and that's
basically saying that the length of this
is one same thing for this side we'll
say the length is one so now when we
want to compute the diameter from here
we're going to maintain a global
variable which I'll call it the result
or this for sure and initially we'll set
it to zero this is what we're trying to
maximize of course and from this node we
calculate a diameter of 1 + 1 which of
course is going to be two now that's the
biggest result that we have now from
this node I want to return up to my
parent the height of this tree so what
do I do well the height is different
than the diameter so we actually will
take the max of the left sub tree the
max of the right sub tree and add one to
it well in this case they're the same so
we just get one and then add one to it
which is this Edge so we'll say that the
height here is going to be two obviously
it didn't have to be like that Suppose
there was a node over here and then
maybe the height of this right tree
would have been two and then we would
have returned 2 + 1 which would would
have been three so that's generally the
core idea we would do the same thing
from here cuz it's kind of symmetrical
to this side so this would be one and
one and then the height of this is two
height of this is two those are going to
be returned up to three add them
together the diameter now is going to be
four it's going to be increased all the
way up to four from here we want to take
the max of left Max of right it's two
and we want to add one to it because of
this edge here so then we say the height
of this part is three we return that up
to the root I'll make it another color
three root is going to do the same thing
take left plus Right add them together
we get three this time it's not greater
than the result so our result will stay
unchanged and it will be four four is
ultimately what we would return but it's
not going to be returned from the
recursive function keep that in mind
we're going to have a separate variable
that's sort of going to be Global which
does that and since we were able to
accomplish this by just visiting each
node once we will say that the time
complexity is linear and the space
complexity is going to be proportional
to the height of the tree which could be
log in for a balance tree or n for a
non-balanced tree so we're going to
solve this recursively and I like to do
it with nested functions so I'm going to
have my DFS here and I'm going to pass
in a single variable Curr remember that
this DFS is not returning the diameter
it's going to return the height that's
the most important thing about this
problem it's not a trivial recursive
problem the base case though is going to
be pretty easy if not Cur therefore we
reached a null node the height of that
is of course just going to be zero so
that's what we return otherwise let's do
the recursive case let's get the height
of the left subtree let's call DFS on c.
left let's do the exact same thing for
the right subtree just like this now
remember there's two things we want to
do we want to potentially update the
result and we want to return the height
of the tree from cerr so let's start
with the result I'm going to create a
variable self. result is equal to zero
this is basically making it a member
variable of this class like an instance
of this class so that it is accessible
inside of this nested function so when I
want to maximize the result I'm going to
set it equal to the max of itself self.
result and the current diameter how do
we get that we'll just take the left and
right and add them together just as we
did in the drawing explanation now for
returning we're not returning this we're
not returning the diameter remember this
Returns the height how do we calculate
the height though well it's either going
to be the max of the left or the max of
the right and also don't forget to add
one for the current node that we are at
this just tells us the max of either of
the sub trees but Plus One will give us
the max of the height from cerr now
that's actually pretty much it it's not
easy to come up with remember the
complexity of this comes from the fact
that the return value is not the result
so down here we're going to return self.
result but don't forget don't be like me
and forget to actually call the
recursive function starting from the
root this is the entire solution you can
see that it works and it's very
efficient I just want to show you a
couple different ways that you could
have handled This Global case though at
least in Python another way is just
making it a local variable result and
then in here to update it let's get rid
of all the self Dots here let's get rid
of that and let's get rid of that to
update result you have to kind of
declare it nonlocal first you want to
say that this is not a local variable to
this function it's actually the same
result that was declared out there so
this will do the same thing so if we
execute this you'll see that once again
it works it says it's more efficient but
leak code run times are random so don't
really pay attention to that if you
found this helpful please like And
subscribe if you want to learn a bunch
of more python tricks check out my
python for coding interviews course and
I hope you have a good day